The WWE that you entered is not the WWE
that you sit in now.
How is wrestling?
Like, how was it to go to like was it
was that the was that the journey all
along? Was it. No, not even close.
This is what I want to get to. This is
what I want to do.
My my whole existence is an accident.
What is
That? What the fuck does that mean?
Well. Well, it's.
My whole existence is based on a series
of fortunate events that kind of lined
up with each other. I did not know that
wrestling was even a career option.
I watched it as a young man kind of
fell out of it as an adolescent, a
teenager, because he's like, Oh, you
got to study hard and maybe play sports
or go to get a real job or whatever.
Went to college, got a degree.
He tried to apply my degree out here in
California. I didn't move out to LA to
to pursue entertainment.
I moved out to apply my degree in
exercise physiology and kinesiology.
So all the god damn, it's basically
just a degree and working out.
So my.
Kinesiology.
Yeah. Kinesiology, the study of movement
of the body. So I, I was passionate
about that at the time I was, I started
working out at 13.
So it's kind of something I knew.
And like, I didn't never felt like I
was going to class, came out here to
try to apply my degree and really
failed. But my dad in a brilliant.
Why do you say failed?
Because I couldn't get a.
Any sort of validation for that piece
of paper that I paid for.
Wow. That four year certificate from
Springfield College saying, we think
you know what you're talking about.
And then I go out to try to I got this.
It's like I don't give a shit.
What do you think?
What do you think that was like when
you said you couldn't get a job?
I mean, having a degree, having a
diploma.
No, I don't know. You know, knowledge is
one thing. Life experience.
Wisdom is another.
Maybe I just didn't. Maybe I rubbed the
people the wrong way. Maybe I didn't.
I didn't know how to carry myself in
interviews. Maybe I didn't search the
right places. This is a 1999.
So it's we're not as interconnected as
we all are now. But I've failed to the
point of like, man, I'm like living in
my car. What?
I love it out here, But I think I got
to I got to go back.
I took the California Highway Patrol
exam, failed, so I was going to be a
cop. Failed every.
Damn it, John this is getting sad.
Every avenue of fitness failed.
Closed door, closed door.
I remember bouncing at a place called
Sharkeez in Hermosa Beach, and there
was a pizza place, Zippy's Pizza, right
next to Sharkeez.
They had a deal where they had a
challenge. If you could eat their whole
pizza, you got it for free.
I used to eat there every night.
A whole pizza, so I didn't have to pay
because I didn't have money to pay the
guy. So I had to like Joey Chestnut.
Hold on.
I'm going to eat another one. Just.
Just to deal with the weight of this
discussion. Wait a second, John.
But.
You know, through through through
uncomfortable situations, we find out
who we are. And I really had to take a
look at like, okay, what do I feel I
have to offer?
Well, well.
Just let me let me just make sure I'm
grasping okay correctly, my guy.
Okay.
I'll take a little bit. Looks like I'm
going to need some, too.
Yeah. No, this is this is good, by the
way. And this is. This is what I mean
about our conversations, Right?
And this is what it was on set.
But on set, we didn't go here, so I'm
homeless.
Well, a Lincoln Continental is a big
car. I live in the back of a 91 Lincoln
Continental for a while. But it was a
it was a 3 or 4 months.
And then I moved into a garage.
So the garage I actually stayed into
for that was like six months.
But it was. And here's the thing.
Like often you hear stories of hard
times. I'm very fortunate for my story
because it was my choice to have hard
times.
Define that. My father always said,
you're you know, you're my son.
I love you. You're always welcome back
home. I had if I could get to West
Newbury, Massachusetts, I would be fed.
I would have a roof over my head.
I would be able to regroup.
I chose to stay out.
You said your father, not your mother.
What is there-
Well. I think at that point, my mom.
I got four brothers.
I think my mom was just happy we were
all in one piece.